rage in the streets of the capital in
what might be a new phase in an uprising
against Lebanon's leadership that is now
in its fourth months fierce
confrontations between anti-riot police
and anti-establishment protesters turned
downtown Beirut into a war zone this is
the epicenter of a protest movement that
until a few days ago was relatively
peaceful running battles began when
demonstrators who want the political
class they blamed for mismanagement and
corruption to leave power tried to storm
Parliament building security forces
responded with tear gas I feel like the
message is for protesters to back off
and that they can't win and I think that
the message of everybody staying here is
that the more police violence they face
the more revolutionary violence they
will face in return
Lebanon's economy has been in turmoil
for months a proposal to tax
what's up tolls which should be a free
service triggered the protests in
mid-october unemployment was rising and
the Lebanese local currency the lira was
losing value we are in an economical
crisis everybody's gonna get hungry
everybody's gonna eat the leaders soon
enough I don't have to convince anybody
about what's happening today it's clear
what's happening who can get a hold of
their money in the banks we lost
everything job finally everything that
this country was 5000 years of history
it is an amazing country they took
everything we have nothing left this is
why our only option is to go down on the
street and ask if it's good violence we
have to use violence who are fighting a
forty-year corrupted government there is
anger at banks which imposed caps on
withdrawals there is a shortage of
dollars anti-riot police have been using
excessive amounts of tear gas to
disperse the crowd but
anti-establishment protesters are
defiant the wounded were in the dozens
both protesters and security forces were
taken to hospitals there is a political
vacuum many Lebanese are growing
impatient with politicians who are
refusing to form an independent
government free of the influence of
political parties instead they are
bickering
among themselves for ministerial posts
in the next cabinet this new government
of alleged technocrats was really just a
smokescreen for the old ruling
oligarchic elite so the protesters were
really upset this is the third night of
violence since Tuesday when activists
said they plan to revive the momentum of
the protest movement after a brief lull
they announced what they called a week
of rage they seemed to be living up to
that promise the United Nations has
already described events in Lebanon as
dangerous chaos it is what comes next
that many fear senator al Jazeera Beirut
about harbors director of research at
the Arab Center in Washington DC he says
the ruling elite just isn't doing enough
to answer the people's demands problem
is the ruling class is not responding
well people on the street want all
they're doing is just postponing and
postponing and postponing the formation
of a new government even though the
protesters have given the new word prime
minister-designate percent yet a whole
month so far to form this will call the
government but apparently he's not being
allowed even by the people who really
nominated him to do that job he's not
being allowed to fold that government so
the economy is really very very in a
very bad shape unemployment the exchange
rate of the the local currency
everything has collapsed and things are
not going well
I mean what's what's happening or since
Tuesday has been expected I mean if
people cannot take it anymore this is we
just entered the fourth month and things
cannot go on like this at all